old friend eric lauer on the mount for
the milwaukee brewers now the first
round pick of the san diego padres in
the 2016 draft out of kent state
obviously been traded away to the
milwaukee brewers he makes his first
start
against his former club to be an
emotional start for eric lauer
fifth appearance in his third start this
year one out two on
fernando tatis junior his 33rd game of
the year
2-0 pitch to tatis and a fly ball hit
out towards deep left field
back goes yelich to the edge of the
track to make the catch
tagging in third and scoring his fam
tagging at second and moving to third
base is mateo
and another sac fly for fernando padres
strike first
and take a one-nothing lead and the
pitch swinging a liner backhanded by
shaw to end the inning he had an
absolute rocket
shaw with a backhanded dive got it
and the inning ends chris paddock
who suffered a loss against the brewers
earlier this season in april it pitched
well but he gave up five runs in the
third inning and then that held up for
the brewers he went five
innings six hits altogether a big winner
his last time out against seattle
fly ball headed out towards deep left
field sending tommy pham back
and again it'll take him to the warning
track but he's there to make the catch
for out number one
and on one and two he goes after yelich
again with a change up and this time he
dots the outside corner
strike three called a one two three
first inning for chris paddock and he
caps it with a k
one out here in the inning in a liner
through the left side a big
hit for carratini padres second hit off
lauer
kim towards left yelich moving over
makes the catch looked like he was
battling the lights a little bit
able to get back to first as those glass
panels up above the brewers dugout i
think
that could be a problem as well
paddock swings and misses it's a zero
put up by eric lauer in the second
first a strikeout for eric lauer one out
base hit by caratini he's left stranded
the addition of the curve ball and that
elevated fastball now he's
a lot more successful is very successful
there lines one down the left field line
he'll
have an extra base hit to open up this
bottom of the second inning
taking what the defense was giving him
take it with the pitchers giving him two
shaw hits it in the air to left field
tommy pham has it sized up
and makes the catch for out number two
lead off double
followed by two fly outs and bring up
willy adams
swings at curveball and what a catch
jake cronenworth up into the air makes
the catch
a magical catch from jake cronenworth
rob's adamus and the brewers as the
padres have a one-nothing lead at the
end of two
so tommy now six out of seven in the
stolen base department
two-two pitch is hit hard on the ground
the other way that'll find its way
through into right center field for a
base hit
lead single tommy pham here in the third
fam is aboard for the second time
cronenworth who took a hit away last
half inning grounds one to first here
has got it
takes to the bag fam goes to third see
the importance of quality first pitches
in at bats for eric lauer they like to
attack him early
002 pitch struck him out of the high
fastball at 95.
big strikeout for eric lowery puts up
another zero here in the top of the
third and there's one away now for eric
lauer
lauer high fly deep left center field
fan
is back on the warning track jabs
another pitcher bomb for the brewers
this time
it's eric lauer tie game yeah
who needs a d8 come on eric lauer
taking his old team deep 2-2 to kane
swinging him as he strikes out and the
inning is over brewers
strike with a solo home run from eric
lauer and they tie this game at one
as we go to the fourth two two to myers
struck him out looking with a backdoor
cutter
it's a pitch you just can't give up on
right one two pitch
struck him out another back door cutter
boy does he have that cutter going
tonight
four strikeouts for eric lower he works
a one two three
top of the fourth
on the ground into the shift again
cronenworth again
out again two down
the pitch popped him up shallow right
hosmer the first baseman goes out into
shallow right and makes the catch in
fair territory
and the brewers go down in order here in
the bottom of the fourth
and the 2-2 pitch to paddock swinging a
miss he strikes him out that's strikeout
number five for eric lauer blew a
fastball by him
and there's two away here's the 1-1
pitch
bouncer to third it's a fair ball shaw
fields throws to first in time
to retire the speedy mateo there is
nothing routine about anything hit on
the ground off the bat of mateos so shaw
did a nice job
helping the brewers get that final out
fernando tatis jr with one out in the
sixth inning
swinging a miss and he strikes out
fernando for the second time tonight
that's six strikeouts for lauer two down
right down the middle right underneath
it good pitch
now hosmer to first tricky hop for hiro
he's got it takes it to the bag how
about six strong from eric lauer tonight
luis urias is gonna pinch hit for lauer
to lead off
fly ball headed to left field on the run
is fam over towards the corner and
fam will make the catch
tommy fam and left field made the grab
ran
out of our sight into the left field
corner and comes up with it for out
number one he went a
very long way to make that catch he did
don
and he was shaded over to that left
center gap
first pitch to kane is fastball swung on
and in the air to right field myers
racing over towards foul ground he gets
there to make the catch
in fair territory on the side warning
track and a one two three sixth inning
for chris paddock
he has set down 11 in a row and hassan
kim
ends up at third base with two down we
are going to have a pinch hitter now
kim getting as much as he wants for a
lead from third
three-two pitch
nasty change-up from voxberger gets him
swinging
and brad boxberger hangs a zero here in
the top of the seventh
and right-hander devin williams yes
devin struck out the side on saturday at
cincinnati
struck him out the airbender of old
right there by devin williams
williams coming back struck him out
and the inning is over he strikes out a
pair wow
nicely done pierce johnson the new
reliever out of the bullpen for san
diego brewers will send up the bottom
part of the order
swinging a miss and he strikes out
adamus to open up the bottom of the
eighth inning
2-2 and that is strike three
back-to-back strikeouts for pierce
johnson two down in the eighth inning
swing and a miss and johnson strikes him
out ends up striking out the side
well josh hader going to try and keep
this ball game tied here in the top
of the ninth inning he's been brilliant
so far this year
11 for 11 and save opportunities and
right now going through the heart of
this order
struck came out high hardware at 97.
3-2 there was a frozen
back-to-back case for hater here it is
hey
struck him out swinging he strikes out
the side
and the brewers come up to bat in the
bottom half of the inning
wow what a dandy and it puts the winning
run into scoring position
the one two from adams lined
to center and coming on to make the
catches pro
far he saves the game for the padres on
the sinking liner
front suitor the new pitcher now for the
brewers
lying the other way into right field for
a base hit myers being waved around
bradley jr will go to second and the
padres will take the lead in the 10th
inning
on top two to one it's a 2-1 ball game
here in the bottom of the 10th inning
and
the padres closer mark malanson is
coming in he's 16 out of 16
and save opportunities first and third
nobody out
last of the tenth on the ground to
second base cornwall is coming home with
it
and they'll tag him out
tried to score and chronoworth comes
home and they get the lead runner for
the first out
on the ground to second base conorworth
will go to first and the padres win